the stars at the playboy party were more  focused on the magazine's new direction  and its first issue without nudity what  the hell am I supposed to hide under my  mattress anymore that's like my whole  childhood has been turned upside out I  don't know what's going on and while  everyone else was partying oh I was  still working sorta appearing with my  buddy Donald Faison in the last webisode  of the Pepsi wrap up online comedy  series the wrong needs to know my  thoughts my life is in the clouds  where's gonna be like being a part of  this show and knowing that what you're  doing here today will be rolled out for  hundreds of millions of people when you  say like that it's a little  nerve-wracking now like I'm a little  nervous I'm in my underwear right here  I'm just saying this is forever yes  greater will grow up and watch this  daddy's into drawers yes sir okay let me  out one leg oh it's all good